CHRIS BROADFOOT: All right.
Santa.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Ho.
Ho.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Hi, my
name is Chris Broadfoot.
I work on the Google Maps
Developer Relations team
based in Sydney.
And in my 20% time, I
was a technical lead
for Santa Tracker.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Hi,
I'm Ankur Kotwal.
And I'm on the Android
Developer Relations team.
In my 20% time last year, I
did Santa Tracker as well.
I was a mobile technical lead.
So thank you for
joining us today.
We have what will be
hopefully a fun talk for you.
We're going to give
you an overview of what
Santa Tracker is as a project.
Then we're going to talk
about how we built it.
And then we'll talk about
some interesting technical
considerations that we
found along the way.
But really, the
key take away here
is that Santa Tracker was built
on Google's Developer platform
using technology that you
can use today and build
similar solutions yourself.
So let's go back to
the very beginning.
In 2004, 10 years
ago, Google acquired
a small company called
Keyhole who had a product also
called Keyhole.
Keyhole actually
became Google Earth.
But in 2004, one
of the engineers
on the product, Brian, decided
to put up a route of Santa
traveling the world.
He did this as just a small
little project on the side.
And he published it
on the Keyhole BBS.
He had the back end
running on a single server
and thought a few people from
this BBS may download it.
He actually had 25,000
unique visitors that night.
And we were just blown away.
It was great.
And we've continued that Google
Santa Tracker tradition now
for 10 years.
So let's see what it
looked like in 2013.
Click.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So we
built a brand new village
with the countdown.
We had some great
animated videos.
We had games,
interactive HTML5 games.
And of course, you can track
Santa across Google Maps.
ANKUR KOTWAL: We also
had an Android app
where you could follow Santa.
And we integrated
with Chromecast
so you could see him
on the big screen.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So we provided
interesting statistics.
You can track center
across Google Earth
and across the whole web
using a Chrome extension.
So we had great HTML5 games
that worked well in mobile.
And we sprinkled Santa
across all Google products,
so Google Maps, on Google
Maps on desktop as well.
ANKUR KOTWAL: That was
Santa Tracker 2013.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So
I'd like to give you
a little bit of an overview
just on the website.
We rebuilt this the
ground up to showcase
the best of Google's
Developer platform.
So as you can see,
there's village
has a countdown where you
can see the time Santa's
going to take off
and these houses that
unlock throughout the
month of December,
kind of like an advent calendar.
So we have these scenes,
just CSS animations, games,
and Easter eggs.
So when you click the
balloon, it just takes off.
It's got some audio
effects as well.
This is one of my
favorite games.
It's a physics game
called Gumball.
And you just rotate
the field of play.
And you drop these
balls into the hopper.
ANKUR KOTWAL: We were able to
bring this to Android as well.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, so
the one was really fun.
And I think this was our
top used game, actually.
So we had this menu that
demonstrated the advent
calendar.
And these things
actually unlocked
throughout the
month of December.
So you can see the
great CSS animations.
We really pushed the
limits of the web.
So we even created
a WebGL HTML5 game.
This is based on Instrument's
Chrome Experiment.
And Santa dives into
your favorite city.
There's these really
silly audio effects
that are kind of charming.
And he just dives through the
candy canes onto a Google map.
So yeah, everything's WebGL.
All of the clouds are WebGL.
And the Google Map
underneath is transformed
using CSS transformations.
It's really cool.
So we also sprinkled Santa
throughout Google products.
This is what it looked
like on Google Maps.
It just prompted people
to go into the website.
And the street view Pegman
donned a Santa hat as well.
So we introduced him into
our mobile applications
as well, just a card on
our maps application.
And you could actually track
him in the Google Earth
application using a KML tool.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So Santa
Tracker actually covers
a lot of Google technology.
As I said, it's built on the
Google Developer platform.
And it's a great way for
us in developer relations
to prove our technology
as well, because it
has a seamless
experience from mobile
to web and through the back end.
And so we'd like to show
you what that is right now.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Right,
so as Ankur said,
anyone can build this.
We're using our
developer platform.
So we had too main experiences.
We had the web application and
the Android native application.
Both of them made heavy
use of Google Maps API, one
of my favorite APIs,
and were both powered
by a Go runtime App
Engine application, which
we called the Santa Tracker API.
Now this is just
our internal API.
But if you do want to build your
own Santa Tracker and use this,
please do get in touch with me.
We'd would love to have everyone
tracking Santa using this.
So it's provided two main
pieces of functionality,
synchronizing time, so
if people's computers
didn't have the right
time, then everyone
would be tracking Santa at
the right time, and also
a feed of his previous
and next destinations.
So all of our clients
would periodically
re-request this information so
that they get Santa's latest
location.
So each destination also
provided a bunch of metadata,
such as when Santa arrived
there, when he departed,
the population, and the number
of presents he delivered up
until that point, so not the
number of presents he delivered
at that stop, but all
the way up until then,
a localized city and region
name, which we showed
in the tracker,
and the location.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yup.
It worked.
Yeah,
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
So this API let us
reach many, many people
around the world,
providing internationalization
into 34 languages.
You can see our
diverse audience here.
So we had people from all
sorts of different locations
and languages.
And you can see the US accounts
for about 32% of our audience.
When reaching a wide audience,
it was also really important
that we support a
variety of screen sizes.
So this is a mock that
we got from a designer,
showing how we'd get the
advent calendar to fit
to a small screen.
You can see the--
well, actually,
first you can see the locking
as we go through the month.
But you'll see some
of the UI elements
disappear as the
screen get smaller.
The back button for
the Go To Village
collapses into separate row.
And the icons go from four
by six to six by four.
So I'm just going to show you
a couple videos showing you
how this works.
So this is our village.
There's a few break points.
You can see the
countdown gets smaller.
We hide a bit of
text just so that we
can show those graphics.
Because we feel they're more
important than that little bit
of text.
Some of the buttons
disappear and rearrange
to fit the smaller
screen as well.
So on the advent calendar,
everything sort of
gets smaller.
The icons have a few breakpoints
to get smaller as well.
And you'll see the Go To
Village button collapse
into a separate row.
And of course the dashboard,
which is quite complex
and shows a whole bunch of
different statistics for Santa,
the text gets smaller as the
screen size gets smaller.
And all of those statistics go
from three by two into a list.
So when building the
site, performance
was really important.
We wanted to make sure
people were engaged,
that the site loads quickly,
the games are responsive.
And the Chrome Developer Tools,
particularly the timeline view,
is really important for that.
When we added snow, we saw an
immediate drop in frame rate,
probably for about 50 frames
per second down to 10 or 15.
And we used the
Chrome Developer Tools
to figure exactly-- figure out
exactly what Chrome was doing.
So it turned out
whenever a piece of snow
fell to the bottom
of the page, it
was triggering a whole
page re-layout, which
is quite expensive.
And we had a lot of snow.
So the Chrome Developer Tools
were really useful there.
There were also really good for
testing your responsive layout,
right.
You can emulate mobile devices.
And the Web Fundamentals website
is a really good resource
for both performance and
multi-device layouts.
To keep the site responsive,
we used a module system.
So each of those experiences we
crafted into a separate module
so that the site loaded really
quickly upon first load.
When the user goes
into a game, they
load that module,
which preloads all
of its assets such
as images and audio
and shows a loading bar
like this to the user, just
to keep them
informed and engaged.
We made really heavy use of
Google Analytics as well,
not just to figure out
where people were engaged
and where we could
make improvements,
but also to track all
of the errors that
happened on the page.
So by adding a global
error listener,
we were able to send those
errors over to Google Analytics
to figure out any problems that
we were having in production.
We actually found a bug that
was only manifesting in IE 10
in Japanese, which
was really strange.
It went straight to the top.
And we were able to fix it.
This is something
that we never would
have found during
manual testing.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So let's
talk about the Android app.
So you'll see here, this is
what our village looked like.
And just like the web, this
was a 12,000 pixel wide image
that we're rendering.
In fact, it's not
a single image.
There's multiple
layers of images here.
We use a technique called
Parallax scrolling, where
the clouds are actually
scrolling at a slower
rate that the foreground,
than the village itself.
And in order to accomplish
this sort of rich detail,
we actually built
a set of-- a code
was written using the
Canvas API on Android.
We found, though,
with the Android app,
we didn't have an
advent calendar
event for every single day.
So instead of having advent
items on the actual village
itself, we started using
these bigger marker pins.
We actually prototyped using the
Navigation Drawer here as well.
And we found that the
Navigation Drawer, which
is a fairly standard and
common patent on Android,
didn't really fit well with
the Santa Tracker experience.
The Navigation Drawer is really
there for primary navigation.
And you typically need more
items in that Navigation Drawer
in order to fill it up.
Otherwise, it just looks empty.
Also, because we were building
what looked like a fairly
custom experience,
almost like a game,
it made more sense to build a
very rich and visual navigation
menu, rather than
just using the Drawer.
But really, the question that
we ask ourselves time and time
again is, why do we want
to build native app?
And it was really
down to performance.
We wanted to build
this rich experience
and have it performed very
well for our mobile users.
We also built these games that
you see on the left hand side.
And so we were able to take
advantage of the accelerometer
on the tilt game, as well
as on the jet pack game.
We had-- it's actually
kind of an action game
where the-- and we'll
see a video in a minute.
But the elf flies
around the screen.
And you have to
collect presents.
So it was really important
that that game, and those sorts
of experiences, stay responsive.
And we could only really get
that level of responsiveness
again through a native app.
The other advantage
of being a native app
is that we implemented
notifications.
In fact, just one notification,
and that notification
went off when Santa took
off on Christmas Eve.
And it was really fun, because
suddenly we started to see all
of these people posting on
Google+ and Twitter that, hey,
my phone just told
me Santa's taken off.
And they would tap
that notification
and jump straight into
that map experience.
But one bit of feedback that
we had from our early testing
was, make that
notification silent.
And make sure it doesn't
vibrate the phone or tablet.
Because when Santa takes
off, around half the world
is asleep.
So they didn't want to get
woken up at 3:00 AM just
because Santa's flying
around the world.
One of my favorite
part of the app
was the ability to use the
Google Maps API for Android.
And you know, that the best
thing for me for this API
is the use of the camera.
And so it's not
just a 2D camera.
It's actually a 3D camera.
So you'll see as Santa
arrives here at Sydney,
the camera zooms in but
also tilts ever so slightly
to give a really good
sort of perspective.
And as you zoomed in on various
cities around the world,
where we had support for it,
3D buildings show up as well.
And they start
popping up on the map.
It just gives a really
immersive experience.
Another part of adding
immersiveness to our map
here was the way that we wanted
the camera to follow Santa.
We really wanted it to feel
like there was someone holding
a camera from way up high,
kind of keeping track of Santa
as he traveled.
And in order to do
so, we made sure
that Santa wasn't always at
the center of the screen.
So you'll often
see that the camera
rotates and spins around.
And sometimes it actually
gets ahead of Santa
and waits for Santa to catch up.
And sometimes it falls behind.
And then it catches up.
So we were able to put
these sorts of effects
in to just make the experience
that much more immersive.
We called this Santa Cam.
Yes, I know-- very original.
On Android, we wanted this app
to be available everywhere.
So again, like a web experience
where we were typically
targeting Chrome,
Gingerbread devices
would have been excluded from
using Chrome for Android.
We wanted to make
sure that this app was
available to all of those users.
And we wanted to make sure it
was available across screen
sizes and form factors.
So we built a responsive
layout on our apps as well.
Now, if you look at the middle
screen shot and the screen shot
to the very right,
you'll see that we've
got a difference between
portrait layouts and landscape
layouts.
We've vertically stuck
the portrait layout,
whereas on landscape we've got
the two views side by side.
But we were also able to put
in this little summary mode
that you can see on the phone on
the left, where you can get rid
of the dashboard and
see more of the map
and see Santa travel
around the world,
and just have a little
summary at the bottom.
And that summary was like
a carousel, where we still
wanted to show those various
statistics from the dashboard,
but we just swiped
them along one by one.
Wed' show how many
presents were delivered,
or what his previous
destination was, or how long
he had been in flight.
Games.
This was really fun
building and testing.
So this game you see
here is the jetpack game
written by an engineer
on our team, Bruno.
And it was actually built
using a custom OpenGL
engine that he wrote in Java.
And yeah, this one was one
that we certainly played a lot
when we were testing the game.
For the other two games, if
you look at the tilt game
at the bottom left,
and you can't really
see the tilting here, but
in order to control it,
it uses the
accelerometer, as well as
the memory match game
on the right hand side.
They just use the standard
Android view hierarchy.
Because we were able to,
again, build a very custom
look and feel and make
it feel like a true game
without having to go to
the extent of building up
a whole engine for it.
Again building using
the right tools
for the job was-- for the type
of job you have, was paramount.
We wanted the
jetpack race, again,
to be faster in fluid
whilst being responsive.
And in fact, when Bruno
tested it on the Nexus One,
he got something like
45 frames per second,
with something like 25
presents on screen at a time.
And so you can imagine
on a device that old
when it performed that well,
from that point forward,
everything was just fast
and fluid from there.
But playing games is great.
But what I like to do is I
like to play games with others.
And these games were
still single player games.
So we started integrating
Play Game services
into Santa Tracker.
What Play Game services allows
you to do is sign in with
your Google+ account and then
participate in the leader
boards and earn achievements.
So from our point
of view, it was
a way of driving
engagement in the app.
But it took off in a way that
we hadn't really anticipated.
For starters, people that
used the Santa Tracker
app are much better
gamers than our team.
In the first 15 minutes
or so of the app being
live, our scores had been,
best scores, had been eclipsed.
The important thing about the
integration with the Play Game
services here was how we
suggested users sign in.
So what you see
with a lot of games
these days is that as
soon as you launch it,
it prompts you to say sign
in with your credentials.
We didn't want to be
so aggressive about it.
What we did instead is
that we waited for the user
to play the game.
And then on the score,
on the high score
screen at the bottom,
you'll see we ask them,
would you like to sign
in to unlock achievements
and participate
in leader boards.
And our sign in rate was
actually very, very high.
People really loved
being a part of this.
So in the months leading up
to Santa Tracker's launch,
Google announced a new
product, Chromecast.
And immediately,
we were fans of it.
We wanted to see Santa
on the big screen.
So Google Santa Tracker was
actually one of the early apps
to integrate with Chromecast.
integrating with Chromecast,
however brought new challenges.
One, it was a big, huge screen.
And it was meant to be
a lean back experience.
So that meant we needed to
take all of the controls
away from the user.
So you might be able to--
is you might have controls
on your website or on your phone
to zoom and move Santa around.
But we wanted to take that away.
Your phone or your tablet
effectively acts like a remote.
So you would drive
it from the phone,
but you wouldn't necessarily
have any interactive controls
on screen.
Chromecast by the way, the
intention of Chromecast
is that you don't
mirror what you're
seeing on your phone or tablet.
What you do is you launch
an experience on there
that's tailored for that screen.
In fact, Chromecast, the
physical size of a Chromecast
is about the size of
a USB flash drive.
It's actually a
low power device.
But it runs the Chrome browser.
So when you cast to the TV,
it actually ran the website.
And some of those
performance tools
that Chris mentioned
earlier really
became important, because
it's a low powered device.
So some of the differences
that you might have seen,
lower snow densities, or fewer
concurrent audio streams.
So we definitely tailored
the experience for it.
So on December 24th, Santa
takes off regardless of
whether we're ready.
So it's a really interesting
engineering project.
Because we can't slip up.
So it's really
important to us that we
make sure we deliver a fantastic
experience on that day,
because there is no
way for us to really
revise it from
that point forward.
So let me show you some of
the techniques that we use.
This is what the desk of a
typical Android Google Santa
Tracker engineer looks like.
Most of our colleagues
walk past our desk
and don't believe
that we're working.
But this is the way we kind
of test Santa in flight.
And you'll see here that
we don't have 3,000 Android
devices, because
it doesn't actually
require that many to test
this kind of experience.
You have a mix of form factors.
So we have some tablets.
We have some phones.
And we have a mix
of screen sizes.
And within these
devices as well,
we have a mix of
operating system versions,
different versions of Android.
And basically, we
were able to represent
the majority of
Android devices just
with a fairly small collection.
Leading up to it,
however we also
need to do full simulations
of Santa in flight.
We call those dry runs.
And this is where the
whole Santa Tracker
team, regardless
of whether you're
working on the mobile
Apple, or you're
working on the web or the
back end, we all get together
and we simulate Santa
journeying across the world.
Now in that simulation,
we have to assume
where Santa's going to land.
Because on the day, I mean we
find out just in time updates
from Santa in terms of
his position, right.
So we make something
up for the simulation.
And we go through the whole day.
And all of us, we have phones,
and tablets, and laptops,
and desktops sort
of simulating Santa.
We want to make sure
that if you turned it on
at the beginning of his
journey, 25 hours later
when he finishes, you're
able to run that through.
And we don't run into
any performance problems
or stability problems.
This photo here is actually of
the Google Sydney reception.
One of our engineers, Jan-Felix,
got a little bit carried away
with the dry run
and took is Nexus 10
and hooked it up to our big
screen in the reception.
And we basically took
it over for the day.
So on that 15th of December when
we had visitors in that office,
they were very
confused as to why
Santa was flying
across their screens.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
so as Ankur said,
we need to make sure that
all of the applications
work functionally.
We also need to make sure that
they can take all of the load.
We see over 100,000 concurrent
users on the website
at some points in time.
And at other points in
time, over 50% of those
were from mobile.
This is what the traffic
shape looks like.
When I first joined
the team, I was
told that we just get
a barrage of users.
But that's actually
not quite true.
It's, as you can see, it's
kind of a gradual growth
which plateaus.
And then they all fall
off as Santa touches
down in the North Pole.
So to make sure the back ends
work, all of our apps work,
we run load tests.
You can see the App
Engine dashboard
while we're running
one of our load tests.
So we actually took this one up
to 10,000 queries per second.
And by taking it up that
far, we were pretty confident
that we were going to be able
to support the main event.
You can see the average
of our instances
was to 250 queries for second.
But we saw some of
them far up to 800 QPS,
which was very good.
And I think this is
largely due to the Go
runtime on App Engine,
which is really, really high
performance.
You can see the memory
consumption is quite low
as well, which is really good.
This is what a graph from one of
Google's front end service-- oh
sorry, back end
service, looks like.
So I think this is from our
Google Maps tile server.
You can see on either
side of Christmas Day,
the traffic is
relatively smooth.
But during Christmas Day
while Santa is running,
the traffic gets
really, really spiky.
You'll also notice that
the volume of traffic
isn't that much higher either.
This is because
the whole of Google
experiences a
little bit of a dip,
so Santa Tracker kind of fills
that gap, which is really good.
Just keeping our
back ends in shape.
So the spiking
nature of the traffic
is primarily because
everyone is looking
at the exact same thing
at the exact same time.
So everyone is hitting
the same kind of requests.
And the largest
spikes I think are
because when Santa's
traveling quicker,
say for example, over
the ocean, or just
quickly across a continent
or something like that,
then people are requesting
many, many more tiles.
So we try to smooth that spiky
traffic using a technique
called jitter.
So the top half of this slide
shows our internal flags,
which we can change
during the event.
And that lets us
delay people randomly.
And we start with two minutes.
So we try to smooth people
out over a two minute period.
So if you opened your phone
and your desktop machine,
you may not actually see Santa
in exactly the same position.
But they'll be pretty close.
We can also control how
often our clients re-request
these flags.
And we jitter those
as well, of course,
just to make sure that the
traffic to our API server
is also quite smooth.
So these flags are stored
in the App Engine data store
and are cached using
Memcache, and also
with the local instance cache.
It doesn't really matter if
these flags are bit stale.
So we can just cache
them in memory.
And those flags come
down to the client
when they're re-requesting these
flags periodically as well.
So you'll see the time
offset field there.
And that should
be the same value
throughout that
user's experience.
So once you're delayed,
you're delayed that amount.
We also use this
endpoint to safeguard
against unexpected events.
We haven't actually
had to use these flags.
But we're able to turn
off entire experiences.
For example, we could shut down
the tracker map on the Android
application, or switch
off the entire website
using these flags.
We can also disable
particular features,
like the tracker
or Google Earth.
Or there was some
problem with our photos,
we could just turn off
the photos as well.
We just kind of added these.
It was really lightweight to
add these in our code base.
So we just had a whole bunch.
We can also make Santa
fly higher or lower
using Google Earth.
And that directly
affects the number
of requests that are being sent
to our Google Earth back ends.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So we use these
flags even in the mobile apps.
So for those of you that tried
to unlock the games early,
this is why you
couldn't get through.
But with that, we just want to
first thank our Santa Tracker
team.
But we also want to
thank you for joining us.
We have collected a whole
bunch of references.
You would have seen
reference documents
throughout the presentation,
things like web fundamentals
or the Android
design guidelines.
We've collected them on one
page for you at this short URL.
And from there, you can
also provide feedback
for this session.
So thank you for joining us.
And we have time for questions.
So if you would like to come
up to the mics and ask any,
here's your opportunity.
Thank you.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
ANKUR KOTWAL: There we go.
That's right.
Don't be shy.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
I've got questions.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Oh,
you've got questions?
AUDIENCE: So do
you guys have kids?
And did they ask you
to ask Santa things
because they know
that you work on this?
ANKUR KOTWAL: So a
two part question.
So I'll answer the first part.
Yes, and my kid basically
throughout this project
found that he would
see more of Santa
as the project got
deeper and deeper.
So he learned to recognize
all of our visual assets.
But he actually learned to
recognize even the music.
So even if I was a
testing like late
at night in a room on the
other end of the house,
he would run around
going, Santa.
I can hear Santa.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
It's quite traumatic.
ANKUR KOTWAL: For me too.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Ok.
So this is a very
interesting project.
I wonder how many engineers
are actually involved
and how much effort is spent.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It varies.
Like we have-- so Ankur and
I and a couple others kind
of core team.
We spend a lot of
time over December.
We've got people that are
20%, sort of like 10%,
especially those that
are integrating it
into the products they work on
every day, like Google Maps.
So there's quite a
varied number of people.
Yeah.
It would be in the
tens, I would say.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Around ten?
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
No, in the tens,
but like 10 to tend
to like 30 or so.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So I mean, so if
you saw one of the screen shots
that we had, we
had on Google Maps,
we had Pegman
having a Santa hat.
Like that will be one
of the engineers that
works in that team.
So it's not a lot of effort
for them to just change
Pegman for that
duration, which is
why Chris is like,
the effort varies.
But the core Santa Tracker
team is about 10 plus people.
But there's more people that
get involved on the periphery.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I realize
Santa's on vacation right now.
Is there any way to find
him, like get him back,
just to show my friends what
this whole thing looked like?
ANKUR KOTWAL: You can
send them the YouTube
link for this presentation.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: There
isn't, unfortunately.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah,
unfortunately not.
But he'll be back
again in December,
if they can wait that long.
All right.
AUDIENCE: Did you guys have any
time to run usability testing?
Because this is like a secret--
it cannot be seen before
Christmas in a way.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, we don't.
And that would be really good.
Like once we started adding--
well, it would be nice to.
Once we started adding a lot
more things to the village,
it got quite difficult to
let people navigate around.
Which is why we added
that six by four menu.
Because the village is
really, really long.
You've got to scroll around.
And that's kind of
the fun of it as well.
You kind of explore the village
as well and enter experiences.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I might
just clarify on that.
We for things like Android
and Google Cast or Chromecast,
we certainly have design
guidelines and UX guidelines.
So we have to definitely
be compliant with those.
And we have a team internally
that also reviews our own apps
and makes sure that
they meet that criteria.
So we do rely on the
same documentation that's
available to developers
everywhere to make sure
that we're doing the
right thing as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for that.
It's a really
interesting project.
I was just wondering
whether there
was any stats available on how
long it took Santa to deliver
each present, or to go
between different locations.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh.
ANKUR KOTWAL: His whole
journey's like 25 hours.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
He flies at-- well,
we don't really know
how he flies as well.
I think it's beyond the
speed of light, I think.
I don't know.
We calculated.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I guess.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
there's some strange physics
going on there.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, those
reindeers are pretty quick.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK.
Well, we'll be around.
So thank you very
much for your time.